Good morning, John.
PAIN!
Today is inspired by a comment on John's video
about me needing to be punished.
I am going to talk about the science of pain,
while experiencing pain.
Let's start out with pain that is detected
by the systems designed to detect pain.
[SLAP]
This is called nociceptive pain.
It's the kind of pain that we need, something
bad is happening, and so our brain is like
"THIS IS UNPLEASANT, RUN AWAY!"
There are three different kinds of nociceptive
pain, first superficial somatic nociceptive
pain.
This is basically skin-based pain.
We have TONS of pain receptors in our skin
because it's our first line of defense, so
we need to gather a lot of information.
When I get whipped, my skin can feel every
single lash of the whip as a separate pain.
Deep somatic pain, on the other hand, is what
we feel when our muscles are burning and when
we have to strain or a sprain or a broken
bone.
It's a less specific pain, but it can extremely
intense.
This is a weird kind of pain test, right now
my muscles are undergoing anaerobic glycolysis,
which is increasing the acidity of my muscles.
Neurons are detecting that increase in acidity
and relaying that signal to my brain as pain.
And, WOW, WOW, that's painful!
ARRRRGH!
The final type of nociceptive pain is visceral
pain.
This is usually pretty vague and distant,
but can also be very intense.
For women, think of cramps.
For guys, think of testicular injuries.
I'm not going to demonstrate this; it would
be dangerous.
Now in addition to nociceptive pain, the other
kind of common pain is neuropathic pain, when
your nerves are damaged or malfunction and
send pain signals when they shouldn't.
One of the only big nerves that runs close
to the surface of the skin is right here,
your ulnar nerve, and if you whack it OOOOWWWWWW
I did it aaaah I achieved - goal accomplished!
Funny bone... that's, that's your neuropathic
pain.
I didn't think I was going to do it so good.
Referred pain, on the other hand, is when
the source of the pain gets mixed up by your
nervous system.
Yes there's a stimulus, but no it is not being
received in the right place.
AAAAAAAAAAAAA OWWW!
My eyes were watering!
Oh good thank God I was recording; I thought
I wasn't recording for a second.
And your nociceptive pain system can also
be tricked and to understand this we kind
of have to understand how the entire nervous
system works.
Cells that detect sensation, whether that's
pain or light or smell, they all kind of work
the same way.
They spend almost all their time maintaining
an ion gradient across the membrane of the
cell, so there's a different charge inside
the cell than outside.
They also, on the surface of the cells, have
these channels that when opened, equalize
that ion gradient, so they become neutrons.
And at the surface of those channels, there's
a protein that's designed to open the channel
when a specific thing happens.
That circumstance can be the presence of salt
or heat or sound or light.
This is how we detect everything.
All of our sensations.
But sometimes, circumstances
that these surface proteins weren't designed
to respond to nevertheless activate them.
For example, there is a protein called TPRV1
that's designed to open a channel in response
to heat, acidity, or abrasion.
But it also, just by chance, opens in the
presence of a molecule called
capsaicin.
Capsaicin is entirely harmless, it does no
damage to your skin, but it does open that
channel so it is detected by your brain as
pain.
And capsaicin is the chemical that makes chili
peppers hot.
OOOH.
AAAALALALA
The burning that I'm experiencing right now
has nothing to do actual damage inside of
my mouth.
It is purely a biological accident, and my
body does not believe it!
Now, pain is an important system.
We live inside of our bodies; we would be
nothing without them, so we have to protect
them.
People who are born without the ability to
sense pain often die before adulthood.
But it's not like a super well designed system
or anything.
It's extremely old.
It's a holdover from ages and ages of evolution
ago.
It leaves a lot of opportunities for things
to go wrong, and so many people have to deal
with chronic pain that is extremely difficult
to manage.
But for most of us, though inelegant and unpleasant,
pain is, oddly enough, something we should
be thankful for.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
Today is inspired by a comment on John's video
about me needing to be punished.
I am going to talpahbababalablahaha lalala.
Me needing to be plalalalala.
Me needing to be- me needing to be memeneeding
beebee.
Tahmah needibala la la LA la la.
Oh my god it got so- first sentence of the
video.
Doesn't hurt, that doesn't hurt, that hurt.
Lindsey: I don't know about this!
Hank: You can do it!
AAAAAAH!!!
Lindsey: I'm so sorry!
Hank: No it wasn't that bad.
[singing] Denver the last dinosaur, he's my
friend and a whole lot more.